comme presque tous les matins le
coiffeur le plus célèbre de france fait
le tour de son immense propriété
il s'appelle jacques dessange
il a 87 ans et il a fait fortune en
coupant les cheveux des français a
priori il a tout pour être heureux dans
son domaine de l'art d'oise en sologne
sa terre natale
jacques dessange a racheté au fil du
temps les parcelles de ses voisins avec
600 hectares c'est aujourd'hui l'une des
propriétés privées les plus vastes de
sologne un paradis pour les animaux
sauvages
[Musique]
il ya deux bandes
ils sont ne sont pas jacques dessange
n'est pas arrivé à la coiffure par
hasard son père était le coiffeur
dessous m
le village voisin c'est de lui qu'il a
tout appris j'ai racheté ce territoire
où je venais enfants à la pêche avec mon
père la vie de très bons rapports avec
votre père fantastique c'était mon père
était un type merveilleux et il m'a déjà
transmis la passion de ce métier
puis je crois que il m'a appris à
travailler tôt le matin il a vu votre
réussite puisque quand il est venu me
voir à paris qu'il a vu mais salon
j'ai demandé s'il ne regrettait pas
d'avoir mené la vie qui l'avait mené
qu'il y aurait pu avant moi faire une
belle carrière n'est pas du tout comment
tu vas faire pour payer tout ce
personnel mathilde un jour je les écoute
j'espère que je vais y arriver
nostalgique de ses débuts jacques
dessange tient à nous montrer une
relique qu'ils gardent à l'abri des
regards dans une pièce de sa propriété
ça c'est le salon où j'ai fait mes
débuts je vais récupérer
il a conservé tous les meubles et
ustensiles de son tout premier salon de
coiffure le fauteuil sur lequel j'ai
aféas j'ai appelé mon métier de coiffeur
pour hommes il a à peu près une centaine
d'années et travaille j'ai commencé à
raser à nos clients de s'abonner d'abord
mon fils mon père rasé ensuite mes
affaires la mousse des barbes j'avais 12
ans
il y à bien des années de cela lorsqu'il
n'avait que 20 ans jacques dessange
simple coiffeur quitte la sologne pour
paris sans un sou en poche grâce à
l'invention de nouvelles coupes et de la
couleur blond dessange son ascension
professionnelle va être fulgurante chez
jacques des singes cette jolie tête
ronde se sauvera volontiers d'un chignon
berlingo toutes les grandes stars de
l'époque ne jurent que par lui
françoise hardy claudia cardinale jeanne
moreau sheila et bien sûr brigitte
bardot c'est jacques dessange qui lui a
créé son célébrissime chignon choucroute
d'une blondeur incandescente dans son
salon de saint tropez
son coup de génie sera d'inventer la
franchise il loue son nom à d'autres
salons de coiffure mais aussi un grand
groupe de cosmétiques
cela fera sa fortune et son empire au
milieu des années 90 dans le monde
1200 salon porte son nom quinze mille
employés et coiffes 70 mille femmes par
jour
[Musique]
en pleine gloire
il épouse sa première femme corinne qui
lui donnera deux enfants cyril et deux
ans plus tard un petit frère benjamin
mais le couple se sépare rapidement
après cette deuxième naissance
benjamin à 23 ans quand il rejoint
l'entreprise familiale
son père le prend sous son aile il
franchit rapidement tous les échelons et
devient l'héritier désigné de l' empire
en 2004 jacques dessange le nomme
directeur général du groupe
et c'est là que tout va basculer entre
le fils et le père les rapports se
détériore en 2010 jacques dessange vend
la totalité de ses actions
il affirme avoir été évincé du groupe
par benjamin toujours directeur général
la guerre semble déclarée
jacques dessange rédiger un livre
incendiaires contre son fils benjamin
poursuit alors son père devant les
tribunaux
[Musique]
par ailleurs la société qu'il dirige
réclame aujourd'hui 7 millions d'euros
de dommages et intérêts à jacques
dessange lui reprochant entre autres des
actes de dénigrement
[Musique]
le clan 200 jo tribunal de grande
instance de paris
le nom dessange et très médiatique la
presse de tout le pays se jette sur le
procès entre le fondateur du groupe et
son héritier après une heure d'entretien
ou les deux hommes ne se sont pas
échangé un regard jacques dessange le
père ressort choqué c'était très dur et
j'ai j'imagine que je pensé en voyant
benjamin que si la honte avait une luge
et une usap un visage humain serait et
benjamin c'est benjamin john finalement
en février 2012
la société créée par jacques dessange et
dirigée actuellement par son fils
benjamin et débouté mais elle fait appel
de la décision du tribunal
le verdict devrait être rendu d'ici
quelques semaines
c'est loin des querelles parisiennes
dans sa propriété de l'art d'oise que
jacques dessange attend la fin de la
bataille
il se ressource ici dans son gigantesque
manoir au milieu des tables de jeu et
des trophées de chasse
le temps ne permet pas de 2 mais alors
quand vous avez tout installer la
piscine
mais ici il peut compter sur le soutien
de ses amis et surtout de sa seconde
femme sally épousé en 2005 elle
travaillait dans le groupe dessange à
taïwan tu va conduire
selon les faire un tour à soi pour se
remonter le moral
il se rend régulièrement à quelques
kilomètres de chez lui un petit voyage
dans le temps pour le patriarche revenir
à l'époque bénie où la famille 200 g
était encore unie et heureuse
le patriarche aime se rappeler l'enfant
simple qu'il a vécu loin de celle qui
l'a offerte à ses enfants la maison ma
mère et aînés c'était la ferme du
château de souesmes à l'époque un peu
plus loin le village natal de jacques
dessange
non ici à droite c'est la maréchalerie
de bon grand-père c'est la maison mon
père est né et en face c'est la maison
où je suis né où il y avait le bistrot
de
mais ça on doit faire de mon père
c'était ma chambre
un peu plus loin c'était le bistrot et
après c'était le salon de coiffure
c'était à l'époque une très jolie maison
quand il a besoin de se confier
jacques dessange se rend chez un de ses
amis d'enfance natif comme lui de la
région alain braud a aussi été le
premier franchisé du groupe le fondateur
vit mal le conflit qui l'oppose à son
fils en dépit de tout il reste convaincu
que benjamin a choisi de faire passer
l'argent l'héritage avant la famille
lorsque les nommer directeur général dû
le virer
je parle de quoi je veux faire il a fait
passer la presse des articles ou 10
benjamin l'héritier de jacques dessange
des séries avant de ces salles on va
passer la main à son fils
comme si l'image à main telle célérité
on hamm est il à occulter complètement
son frère qui vient de foot qui a foutu
dehors des en même temps que moi c'est
dommage c'est toujours très triste
d'avoir des parents et des enfants qui
en arrive là
certains pourraient tuer père et mère
pour réussir la mère de benjamin est
mort depuis longtemps mais a tué son
père se dit pas certain et la cellule de
m
je résiste toujours une question
d'héritage une question de fric le fric
benjamin qui n'a pensé qu'à l'argent
depuis ce depuis son enfance
l'argent l'argent l'argent l'argent fou
l'argent rend fou
avoir un héritier modèle c'est le rêve
de tous les fondateurs d'empyr dans la
famille dessange père et fils ne
réussissent pas à s'entendre mais dans
d'autres familles très fortunés certains
enfants font tout pour ne pas décevoir
leurs parents et être à la hauteur de
l'héritage à venir quitte à supporter la
pression d'un patriarche très exigeante
ce soir dans sa résidence parisienne
située sur l'une des avenues les plus
somptueuses de la capitale il a invité
ses amis les plus proches pour tenter
d'oublier cette bataille familiale
une bataille qui fait souffrir le vieux
patriarche dans les 250 m² de son
appartement haussmannien
il y a là des avocats des promoteurs
immobiliers et des hommes d'affaires
tous comprennent très bien les problèmes
d'héritage de jacques dessange et sa
douleur de perdre et sue sa femme sally
c'est que ces moments sont précieux pour
le patriarche
[Musique]
une fois par semaine il a des copains
qui vient à la maison guinée joue au
billard présentant quelques parties de
poker et cette fois pas semaine de plus
d'importants activités à la maison
kojak en cuisine comme à chaque fois
c'est omar le fidèle majordome qui
prépare le dîner
cela fait plus de deux décennies qu'il
travaille pour jacques dessange
mercredi ça fait plus de 25 ans cet
ouvrage bridge elle et ça c'est pas pire
qu'avant je connais piles et comment
dans cette es pire quand j'arrivais le
matin à 8 heures les était toujours là
je me demandais s'il prend tous les vip
à table
mettez-vous à côté de ceux qui vous sont
au sympathique porcelaine de luxe verres
en cristal et argenterie c'est le dîner
à la bonne franquette version de sange
pourtant il semblerait que ce soir il y
est un raté dans le rituel
il n'y a pas de vins blancs du tout non
c'est pas possible ça au mas on va pas
manger du poisson avec des quel dommage
y'a pas de vin rosé non plus
vous allez manger du poisson avec du vin
rouge se désole omar a mis le portait du
vin blanc un petit imprévu
mais grâce à ses amis et à sa femme
jacques dessange va vite retrouver sa
bonne humeur
ce sont eux aussi qui lui permettent de
tenir bon dans la guerre avec son fils
benjamin
si j'ai résisté à tout ça c'est grâce à
s'allier à vous votre amitié vous m'avez
témoignée le temps que j'ai passé avec
vous quand je joue aux cartes ou à la
chasse je suis oublier mes problèmes
donc ce soir je profite de l'occasion
pour vous remercier tous de l'être mais
va porter ce moment là et que vous
conduisez aborder maintenant et vous
allez devoir encore quand il veut pas
d'apporter parce que ce n'est pas
terminé
dans ce combat avec benjamin le
fondateur de l'empiré dessange peut
aussi compter sur un autre allié de
poids son deuxième fils
retour en sologne à l'ardoisé dans la
propriété familiale
cyril 51 ans est le fils aîné de jacques
leurs rapports ont souvent été
conflictuelle mais aujourd'hui cyril
aime passer du temps au côté de son père
ces deux amoureux de la nature passe des
heures à parcourir en quad leur immense
domaine qui leur réservent parfois des
surprises bien étrange
sèmassi denis ce que tu me reconnais est
ce que tu me reconnais sidonie est ce
que tu me reconnais pas ce que tu
reconnais l'habiter la maison qu'elle
nous suivait vraiment comme un chien et
puis on la pensait que sa vie de deux
messti que je cochon n'était pas sa
nature donc à la remise dans un parc
ici avec d'autres sangliers et la db
alors ce sont des bébés 2 ceci donne
issue relance
pendant une quinzaine d'années cyril a
été le directeur de la communication du
groupe dessange avant de voler de ses
propres ailes
en 2008 il réintègre le giron familial
mais deux ans plus tard comme son père
il affirme avoir été évincé par son
frère benjamin conséquences jacques
dessange s'est rapproché de celui qui
aurait pu être son héritier numéro un
il me soutient il fait partie de ceux
qui m'ont permis de durer depuis deux
ans avec sally et tous mes copains et il
a été à ce cours très très important il
était viré par son père comme moi je ne
pensais pas qu'il était capable d'aller
jusqu'au bout peut être en désaccord
avec son père vainqueur aujourd'hui vous
dit que peut-être cyril aura été un
choix plus judicieux et bien sûr bien
sûr
cyril a été plus dans le groupe
il avait tenté il avait entreprise d'un
business complètement indépendant qui
marchait bien d'ailleurs
et puis ces époques a aussi benjamin me
faisait beaucoup de il était beaucoup
plus gentils avec moi il
il se préparait à me couler davantage et
il me faisait du charme
oui ça m'a préparé son coup depuis fort
longtemps nous avons eu des
conversations séoul justement à ce
propos au
j'avais bien compris que d'abord il
n'avait pas l'intention partager son
trône comme il disait
deuxièmement il a l'intention de
l'ancien mexique des avantages j'ai bien
compris que sa volonté était de faire le
vide autour de lui pour cyril après tant
de déchirements
une réconciliation familiale semble
impossible même s'il sait que son père
l'espère encore ils rejettent sans
l'autre que pour ces dernières années on
ne sera pas tous en famille mon frère
ses enfants mon fils et moi mais là je
pense que c'est la plus grand chose à
faire un point de non retour qui a été
dépassé il ya déjà longtemps qu on ne
poursuit pas son père on peut ne pas
être d'accord avec sans peur assaillent
et la crise taux de naissance à l'état
c'est le complexe d'oedipe longtemps
qu'il aurait dû la voir ses aveux c'est
un peu plus du ridicule c'est un non
sens là pas de logique
benjamin dessange refuse d'évoquer ses
rapports avec son père il préfère
laisser répondre
son avocat selon lui c'est jacques
dessange qui est responsable de cette
situation conflictuelle
il n'y a pas d'affaires de sange il ya
un problème qui concerne jacques
dessange
donc je pense qu'il a une vision c'est
par ces l'air vicié des choses non
seulement il n'a pas été éjecté du
groupe dessange mais c'est de son propre
chef qui l'a vendu les actions qu'il
possède dans ce groupe qu'il a fait
fortune grâce à cette cession
appartement où il s'est dessaisi de sa
propre volonté de son propre fait de son
bébé qu'il avait créé il s'en est
trouvée orphelins et a fini par entrer
dans une phase de dépression ou de
décompensation et il en veut un peu
aujourd'hui à tous ceux qui font
perdurer et surtout prospérer son nom de
le perdre un comportement qui est
irrationnel il a beaucoup de mal à
supporter que ceux qui ont repris le
flambeau fasse mieux encore que lui
[Musique]
à ce jour jacques dessange n'a pas revu
son fils depuis plus de deux ans